well we don't arrest chickens for
clucking but I do think we ought to you
know how I could have told that that guy
was going to be a problem you know how I
could have told because he's wearing a
mask and it was always very ridiculous
to wear a mask it was always very
ridiculous but it's especially
ridiculous in this moment that's all
right his little whistle isn't too loud
so I think we can probably get through
it
oh
two important babies go to heaven do
aborted babies go to heaven
well it's a complex issue there's
there's the matter of limbo
you're right but there's a matter of
limbo because well I don't think he
really cares about an explanation of
this but if anyone's interested in the
finer points of Catholic theology I'm
more than happy to discuss them
afterward anywho all right enough of
that guy